well good evening bad news i'm afraid to
start amber heard is still yapping uh
she's broken her silence which didn't
last very long in a new sit-down
interview after her defamation trial
lost to ex-husband johnny depp insisting
that he's the liar and repeating claims
he assaulted her during their marriage
because we've heard all this before
haven't we and the more that she whines
and plays the victim rather like that
other american actress megan markel the
less credible she becomes
this was the most humiliating and
horrible thing i've ever been through in
the vast majority of this trial was
played out on social media the jury saw
it
how could they not it would have been
impossible to avoid this he says you
start physical fights and you say i did
start a physical fight i can't promise
you i won't get physical again
i mean this is in black and white i
understand context
but you're testifying and you're just
telling me today i never started a
physical fight and here you are on tape
saying you did as i testified on the
stand about this is that when your life
is at risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic psychologically emotionally and
physically you don't have the resources
that say you or i do with the luxury of
saying hey this is black and white but
then there are other times there's
another tape where you're taunting him
and saying oh tell the world johnny depp
i a man the victim of domestic violence
20 second clips or the transcripts of
them
are not representative of even the two
hours or the three hours that those
clips are excerpt from he says it
doesn't never
hit you he never is that a lie yes it is
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyers called your testimony the
performance of a lifetime what do you
say to that says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers when i asked
his lawyers why do you think you won and
the answer i got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything
she did in the marriage
i
did do and say horrible
regrettable things throughout my
relationship do you think that maybe he
just had better lawyers i will
say his his lawyers did certainly a
better job of distracting the jury from
the real issues do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony i'm joined
now by civil rights attorney lisa bloom
lisa lovely to talk to you again um
when i watched this this morning on the
today show i've got to be honest with
you my mind went back to meghan markle's
oprah winfrey to uh wine-a-thon
because the longer amber heard talks
frankly
the more she whines the more she plays
the victim the more she tries to blame
everybody but herself
as with meghan markle the less i believe
her i just find her a really incredible
or uncredible witness or both actually
well you certainly have a right to your
opinion piers and i have a right to mine
i have a lot of sympathy for amber heard
i agree with the couple's marriage
counselor that they were both abusive to
each other and there's no question that
she was vilified on social media as she
says she had to go into court past
blocks and blocks of johnny depp super
fans holding up signs that she deserved
to die i mean this was a horrific
experience for her she stands by her
testimony my concern for her is is she
going to get hit with a new defamation
case because now she's out there calling
him a liar right and also my question
would be if johnny depp had lost that
case would he have been allowed on the
today show to call his victim a liar to
stand by everything that he'd said i
don't think he would have been given the
platform so to me there's a double
standard there you've been involved in
many of these these cases i know but i
think there's a real double standard
there
i think that today's show would have
been thrilled to have him on if he lost
to tell his side or any of these
high-profile guys uh who are accused i i
don't think that's a problem i don't
think he has a problem having a platform
he's got a massive platform he's an
a-list celebrity he's wealthy beyond
all-imagining i don't think that would
have been no i don't think well i don't
think this was a good idea for amber
though no i thought it was a total train
wreck for her but my point being i don't
think that today's show would have given
johnny depp the chance to continue
playing the victim if he'd been found
guilty of domestic violence and my issue
watching amber home was a jury didn't
believe her you know 95 percent of the
of the virgin went johnny depp's way
they thought she was the liar and in
fact the only hard evidence that came
out during the entire case
about domestic actual violence physical
violence was by her not by johnny depp
yes but keep in mind she used the term
domestic abuse which includes emotional
abuse sexual abuse psychological abuse
she never said in that op-ed that was
the center of the whole case that he
physically abused her and i also think
samantha guthrie at the today show did a
pretty good job she's an attorney i know
samantha a little bit she's tough and i
think she did a pretty good job of
saying look just as you just said piers
look amber heard uh the jury didn't
believe you the jury felt that you were
a liar i mean she really you know
did a pretty tough interview there you
know the problem i have lisa with with
the whole thing with amber heard and
i've got no great truck for johnny depp
by the way i think he came out of it
pretty awfully too
but i think his behavior since has been
a lot more respectful to the process he
certainly hasn't you know tried to
hammer things home with with amber heard
in the press by you know continuing to
rant about her but my whole problem with
it if you go back to that first piece
that she wrote we now live in a in a
culture in a society where there is a
premium to people to play the victim to
write these kind of heart-rending op-eds
positioning themselves as these terrible
victims
what became clear through this case was
that at very best this was a mutually
toxic
abusive situation she certainly wasn't
the victim
and yet there she was taking space in a
major national newspaper to write this
searing op-ed as a kind of
representative for the victims of
domestic violence and i think that that
goes to in my mind
this culture we now have where people
can build a career out of victimhood and
many of them do it and i think it
diminishes
real victims people who are really
suffering
really being abused really the victims
of domestic violence and i'm cynical
about it and i'm seeing it more and more
and i'm like what is happening when
when there's that mindset
well i i don't necessarily agree with
you piers that people make careers out
of victimhood because i represent dozens
and dozens of victims of sexual abuse
and race discrimination right now in my
law firm and i can tell you no none of
my clients want to be in this position
they wish it never happened they wish
they could just go on with their lives
most of them never do any media they
just want justice they just want some
fairness and accountability and with
regard to amber heard and johnny depp
they can both be victims and i think
there are many marriages where the both
parties abuse each other and it's
horrific and they can both be hurting
and in the article she talked about the
massive backlash that she had gotten in
hollywood for saying that she was a
victim and clearly what we've seen a
massive social media hate for amber
heard and and what she's had to
experience in the last couple of months
of this trial uh not it's not something
but again you know i i
agree
look i don't i don't like the social
media pile on with her it can get very
nasty very ugly but her insinuation the
jury must have been reading all this and
that's why they found against her i
think is extremely in my view
disrespectful to the process to the
court case to the jury it's like i'm
pretty sure they're not allowed to read
any social media so maybe one or two did
we don't know we're not supposed to
right so
you're not supposed to but you and i
know
piers when was the last time you were
off of twitter for six weeks
uh probably before twitter
twice six minutes most of us are pretty
addicted
most of us are pretty addicted to social
media whether it's instagram or twitter
or whatever it is and to say that they
were all entirely off for six weeks that
none of their friends and family members
talk to them about it i mean do we
really believe that nobody could be it
could be lisa work with juries
and they do another thing i know but
ultimately to me
it comes back to this thing where all
women must be believed as a starting
point for these kind of cases i think
all women should be listened to and
evidence should be studied
but i think the clear
overwhelming sort of fallout from meghan
markle oprah winfrey amber heard in this
court case is that actually no not all
women should be automatically believed
because sometimes they're telling
porcupines
well listen no sane person says that all
women must be believed i mean that's
absurd i think you're right a lot of
people do say that any accuser i
represent men
i don't know about a lot of people
saying that peers maybe there's always
fringe people on both sides of things
but i think we want to take these
allegations seriously i think what the
metoo movement has taught us that a lot
more people are sexually abused and
sexually harassed than we ever knew in
the past and we're all taking this a lot
more seriously and we should and a lot
of prominent people mostly men have been
taken down by the metoo movement and
they should have and so overall it's a
positive thing but there's always going
to be outliers people who make up
stories and we have to have due process
i agree with you i listen i agree with
everything you just said i think i think
that most of the me too movement and
time's up movements have been uh long
overdue and very necessary a lot of bad
people have been held a proper account i
just think when i watch someone like
amber heard i see an actress
and i see somebody who lost but who
doesn't want to admit she lost she's a
kind of donald trump
johnny depp is a more successful actor
sorry
johnny depp yeah but johnny dick johnny
he's a far more successful actor why
isn't he accused of acting well he's on
the stand i just know if johnny depp had
lost there's no way he'd have been
allowed to carry on calling his victim a
liar on prime time american television
they wouldn't have allowed it
well you know i'll defer to you you know
more about television than i do i'm just
a simple civil rights lawyer
representing victims i'm not actually
sure about that see you're a very
accomplished television performer this
day great to talk to you thank you very
much
always good to see you thank you peers